[Applaus]
[Musik]
das heutige video wird eine frage
beantworten die ihr euch alle schon
einmal gestellt habt was bringt es mir
visual politik zu schauen was ist es mir
zu wissen was in einem land mit öl
passiert wenn ich nicht einmal weiß wo
dieses land liegt das heutige video
zeigt dass das was dir auf diesem kanal
erzählen die ich persönlich mehr
betrifft heißt du vielleicht denkst egal
aus welchem land du dieses video schaust
du wirst einfach mal einen blick auf die
strom- und gasrechnung dieses monats und
du weißt wovon wir sprechen außer du
hast mit einem versorger im voraus
langfristig fixierte preise vereinbart
aber auch diese verträge werden
irgendwann auslaufen und ich versichere
dir das auch dann versorger diese dann
ganz schnell anpassen wird und ich weiß
nicht ob das ist ein trost für dich ist
du bist nicht der einzige der dieses
problem hat wir reden hier über eine
wirklich besorgniserregende entwicklung
kryptisch bauer warnt vor einem massaker
auf den energiemarkt
angesichts steigender preise könnten
millionen menschen in europa
schwierigkeiten haben ihre häuser zu
heißen also nein du bist nicht der
einzige der ein problem hat das gleiche
passiert in ganz europa und auf dem
ganzen planeten sowohl in asien als auch
den usa schießen die preise in die höhe
und explodierender energiepreise sind
ein problem für die wirtschaftliche
erholung nach dem corona stadthaus viele
geben der regierung der schuld und jeder
gibt der regierung des eigenen landes
die schuld aber die wahrheit ist dass
wir vor einer globalen krise stehen wir
stehen vor der ersten großen krise der
energiewende die frage ist also warum
sind die energiepreise in die höhe
geschnellt wie langsam wird die
situation noch andauern wie hoch ist das
risiko dass sie sich wiederholt oder da
noch steigert und was noch wichtiger ist
wie könnte der ausweg aus dieser krise
aussehen heute werden wir nicht nur all
diese fragen beantworten sondern die
auch unseren neuen sponsor vorstellen
dich also natürlich nur falls du das
auch sein möchtest viele von euch haben
uns ja immer wieder geschrieben dass sie
unsere arbeit gerne finanziell
unterstützen würden und diesen wunsch
möchten wir jetzt und auch uns erfüllt
ihr könnt es also bei uns in der
redaktion so richtig weihnachten lassen
in der beschreibung unter diesem video
findest du einen paypal spenden link mit
denen du uns eine kleine aufmerksamkeit
zukommen lassen kannst dies kann ein
regelmäßiger betrag sein oder passend
zur weihnachtszeit auch eine üppigere
spende oder gerne auch beides ist ja für
einen guten zweck denn mit euren
regelmäßigen spenden können wir
natürlich besser kalkulieren und
unabhängiger von werbeeinnahmen werden
zum beispiel können wir dann das
deutsche team vergrößern noch öfter noch
bessere videos herausbringen und die
zahl der werbeeinblendungen reduzieren
wäre es nicht großartig andere auf
diesem weg gemeinsam eine stabile
grundlage unserer arbeit hinbekommen
könnten unabhängig von netzwerken
medienhäusern oder zwangsgebühren so
eine sogenannte grundversorgung die in
deutschland ja mittlerweile bei über 220
euro pro jahr liegt also überlegte bitte
welche spendenhöhe dir persönlich für
visual politik.de vorkommt und geht es
gleich auf den link unten in der
beschreibung das video läuft der ja
nicht weg übrigens brauchst du das nur
kein eigenes paypal-konto sonst dort
auch direkt per kreditkarte spenden wir
bedanken uns bei dir schon im voraus für
die freundliche unterstützung und wenn
du wieder zurück kommst lassen wir erst
mal einen kurzen blick in die
wechselvolle geschichte der
energiepreise
[Musik]
die ära der energie im überfluss
unsere heutige geschichte ist eigentlich
ziemlich simpel natürlich gibt es auch
politische aspekte aber hier geht es
einfach nur um pure wirtschaft das
gesetz von angebot und nachfrage während
der mutter aller ölkrisen im jahr 1973
vervierfachte sich der preis des dinos
nachdem die arabischen länder
beschlossen hatten ihre produktion
extrem herunterzufahren weniger angebot
gleiche nachfrage ergibt höherer preis
wir können uns auch ansehen was im jahr
2011 passiert ist der ölpreis erreichte
seinen damaligen höchststand dank der
überbordenden nachfrage aus den
aufstrebenden china höhere nachfrage
gleiches angebot führte zum gleichen
ergebnis einen höheren preis dieser
trend hielt bis zur fracking revolution
die ölpreise sind zwischen 1971 und 2011
inflationsbereinigt um fast 900 prozent
gestiegen zur veranschaulichung andere
grundlegende rohstoffe sind im selben
zeitraum um 68 prozent gestiegen als
sich der ölpreis bei über 100 us dollar
pro barrel eingependelt hatte waren
jedoch die voraussetzungen geschaffen um
die ausbeutung von öl und gasfeldern
durch fracking rentabel zu machen vor
allem natürlich in nordamerika diese
technik war auf den weltweiten
energiemärkten eine echte revolution
plötzlich gab es ein viel größeres
angebot an erdöl und infolgedessen sank
der ölpreis im jahr 2014 um fast die
hälfte
diese ära gilt im energiesektor ist die
jahre des überflusses ironie des
schicksals die fracking revolution
schickte den ölpreis gerade zu jener
zeit in den keller als die
weltöffentlichkeit begannen den
klimaschutz ernst zu nehmen eine 2015
wurde das pariser abkommen der pfeiler
im kampf gegen den klimawandel
ausgehandelt man schickte sich an
erneuerbare energien wie wind und
solarenergie durch staatliche eingriffe
in die märkte wettbewerbsfähiger
gegenüber anderen brennstoffen wie kohle
und erdgas zu machen die zirkus
aussichten hätten nicht rosiger sein
können kohle und gas bleiben will ich
aber erneuerbare energien gewinnen das
rennen um die niedrigeren kosten
in einem bericht für 2016 senkte
bloomberg new energy finance seine
langfristigen prognosen für kohle und
gas frei sungen verein drittel sie
gingen davon aus dass die preise
angesichts des erwarteten über angebote
beiden energieträgern fallen würden und
natürlich bedeutet für diese prognose
auch niedrigere strompreise oder gas und
kohle in der regel dann eingesetzt
werden dann kernkraft wasserkraft und
erneuerbare energie nicht ausreichen um
die stromnachfrage zu decken
[Musik]
alles lief wie am schnürchen
geschmeidiger geht's nicht alles sah
nach einer strahlenden zukunft ohne
energie sorgen aus doch seit der
verabschiedung des pariser abkommen es
kam eine bewegung auf die mit der zeit
immer stärker wurde ihr ziel war es die
investitionen in die erschließung
fossile brennstoffe zu reduzieren die
kampagne erfasst da institutionelle
investoren und auch privatanleger
tatsächlich haben wir danach richten
erlebt von denen wir nie gedacht hätten
dass sie eintreten würden die erben des
rockefeller öl vermögens ten sich wegen
des klimawandels von fossilen
brennstoffen in den letzten fünf jahren
wurde in der branche über nichts anderes
mehr gesprochen als über energiewende
und planeten rettung deren erklärtes
ziel ist nichts geringeres als die
weitere erwärmung der erdatmosphäre
aufzuhalten indem die treibhausgas
emissionen aus der verbrennung fossiler
brennstoffe durch den menschen herunter
gefahren werden oder wie man neuerdings
sagt die wirtschaft dekarbonisierung
wird
diese umstellung erzeugt einen starken
druck auf die ölgesellschaften
insbesondere auf die europäischen kein
neues kapital in die erkundung und
förderung von fossilen brennstoffen zu
investieren die daten sprechen für sich
noch 2014 wurden mehr als 800 milliarden
dollar in die erkundung neuer dino sagt
vorkommen gesteckt heute ist dieser
betrag auf weniger als die hälfte
gesunken
globale upstream investitionen sinken
auf ein 15-jahrestief und werden 2020
auf 383 milliarden us dollar sinken
[Musik]
da ist zum beispiel der fall des
ölkonzerns royal dutch shell im jahr
2014 als die rohölpreise über 100 dollar
pro barrel lagen investierte das
unternehmen mehr als 30 milliarden
dollar in upstream projekte das heißt in
explorationsprojekte für neue ölfelder
heute investieren sie weniger als acht
milliarden dollar außerdem haben sich
fast alle ihre fracking projekte in
texas verkauft und sie denken darüber
nach alle ihre felder in nigeria und das
ist ein ganzer haufen loszuwerden
und ich weiß dass viele von euch denken
da planet muss sich freuen wie ein
schneekönig wenn selbst das großkapital
den fossilen brennstoffen den krieg
angesagt hat kann doch gar nichts mehr
schief gehen nun das kann ist leider
doch denn in dieser realität ist alles
mit einem preisschild versehen selbst
etwas derart von ihr losgelöstes wie
planeten rettung und wiegt dieses
preisschild noch werden kann werden wir
uns jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
der cobra effekt
wenn du mal versucht hast ein problem zu
lösen und ist dabei noch schlimmer
gemacht hast bist du zu einem weiteren
der vielen opfer des cobra effects
geworden dieser effekt heißt so weil es
zu zeiten des britischen empire viele
giftige kobra in indien gab die
vergiftungen durch kuba bis verursachten
der kolonial regierung hohe
krankheitskosten also setzt die briten
ein bußgeld für jede tote cobra aus und
jetzt weiß ich was du denkst geld hilft
immer so wurden sich ja alle kobras
getötet und oberflächlich betrachtet war
es auch eine klassische
win-win-situation wie aus dem lehrbuch
du könntest eine tote kuh opera ist
damit der allgemeinheit geld zu sparen
und bekommst dass so etwas davon als
belohnung das problem war nur dass die
schlausten in der lieber cobras
züchteten als die mühsam draußen zu
jagen als sie bemerkten dass sie einen
haufen geld für toto kobras ausgaben die
plage aber kein bisschen nach ließ
stellten sie ihr kuba cockpit programm
von einem tag auf den anderen wieder
eine das problem das cobra kopfgeld
business war mittlerweile so riesig
geworden dass unzählige einheimische auf
den zug aufgesprungen waren und
unzählige farben voller cobras aufgebaut
hatten und da ist nun kein geld für die
cobras cup ließen sie einfach als
nächstes frei und ich sage dir eine
solche cobra schwämme hat das land noch
nie gesehen plötzlich gab es mehr cobras
als je zuvor das cobra bekämpfung
programm hatte das ursprüngliche problem
also nur noch maßlos verschlimmert und
ja es war sicher nicht das erste und
auch nicht das letzte mal dass politiker
ihren bürgern den weg in die hölle mit
guten vorsätzen gepflastert haben heute
in der korona erleben wird davon ein
paradebeispiel nach dem anderen und wo
politiker krone lösen wollen ist auch
das zweite lieblingsthema der experten
für die rettung vor allem nicht weit das
klima wie er ist hat man dir von visual
politik noch nie probleme mit
umweltschutz sondern auch nicht mit
umweltfreundlicher energie aber wir
glauben dass das tempo mit dem die
selbst ernannte weltenretter die
energiewende vorantreiben das wahre
problem an der ganzen geschichte ist
den investitionen in saubere energie
müssen sich auf der internationalen
energieagentur bis 2030 verdreifachen um
den klimawandel einzudämmen ganze zwei
drittel der investitionen im
energiesektor werden bereits in
erneuerbare energien gesteckt aber wie
du siehst sind noch viel mehr
investitionen nötig wenn die gesteckten
klimaziele erreicht werden soll wenn
aber bereits zwei drittel aller energie
investitionen in grüne energieerzeugung
fließen und dieses ich bin acht jahren
verdreifachen müssen so zwei drittel mal
drei ergibt sechs drittel wir kürzen
ergibt 2 das heißt dass wir binnen acht
jahren mindestens doppelt so hohe
investitionen im energiesektor
finanzieren müssen als bisher und selbst
das unter der vollkommen unrealistischen
voraussetzungen dass gar nichts mehr in
fossile energieträger investiert werden
muss dieses geld kommt also noch oben
drauf so und das alles diese ganzen
mehrkosten müssen von irgendjemandem
bezahlt werden und deshalb sagen wir es
wäre besser mit dem tempo vorsichtig zu
sein denn einige energiequellen müssen
durch andere ersetzt werden und zwar im
rahmen eines guten platz denn am ende
wenn es schwierigkeiten gibt bleiben die
probleme und die rechnungen nicht bei
der regierung oder den energiemanagern
liegen sondern bei tieren und die
schwierigkeiten sind schon da
deutschland gehört mit einer
energiekrise wird gleichzeitigen atom
und kohle ausstieg wir haben es bereits
eingangs gesagt knappheit ist als
synonym für steigende preise aber gut
lasst uns die energiewende im
schweinsgalopp vorantreiben herr mit der
bitteren pille damit die es hinter uns
haben vielleicht sollten wir aber mal
einen kurzen moment die packungsbeilage
lesen das problem bei erneuerbaren
energien ist wie du sicher weiß dass sie
extrem von den wetterbedingungen
abhängig sind man kann sie nicht nutzen
wann immer man will oder braucht ohne
wind bewegt sich kein windrad und wenn
die sonne nicht scheint liefert die
photovoltaik anlage weniger als lance
armstrongs fahrrad dynamo wenn er gerade
drunter ist was wir als ergänzung zu
wind- und sonnenenergie brauchen ist
also grundlast energie
[Musik]
werke von denen wir wissen dass sie uns
nicht im stich lassen werden und die
gerade dann verfügbar sind und vor allem
skalierbar sind wenn wir sie brauchen
wir könnten dazu wie im 19 jahrhundert
einfach kohle verfeuern aber das ist nun
wirklich bei wenn diese stoßen nicht nur
kohlendioxid aussagen belasten menschen
umwelt auch durch weitere schädliche
emissionen für viele überraschend mit
jeder kilowattstunde kohlestrom wird
weitaus mehr radioaktivität freigesetzt
als bei atomstrom die strahlenbelastung
von menschen durch förderung und
verbrennung von kohle ist deutlich höher
als diejenige durch kernkraftwerke denn
cola enthält spuren verschiedene
radioaktiver substanzen vor allen radon
uran und thorium bei der kohleförderung
vor allem aus dem tagebau über die
abgase von kraftwerken und über die
kraftwerke werden diese substanzen
freigesetzt die bindung an staubpartikel
ist dabei besonders kritisch und so
werden in der umgebung von
kohlekraftwerken höhere
strahlenbelastungen gemessen als in der
nähe von kernkraftwerken die weltweit
jährlich allein für die stromerzeugung
verwendete cola enthält unter anderem
etwa 10.000 tonnen uran und 25.000
tonnen podium zu vergleich zu ihrer
hochzeit notierten alle deutschen
atomkraftwerke zusammengenommen jährlich
etwa 450 tonnen an radioaktiven abfällen
das ist nur 1 77 der menge aus
kohlekraftwerken aber was nützen all
diese argumente kernkraftwerke sind auch
extrem unbeliebt auch wenn sie kein co2
ausstoßen viele menschen haben eine
heidenangst vor einem gau also schalten
wir doch einfach auch die atomkraftwerke
ab und was bleibt dann übrig nun wir
könnten erdgas verbrennen es ist zwar
immer noch ein fossiler brennstoff aber
die verbrennung von erdgas stößt weniger
co2 pro erzeugter terawattstunde aus als
kohle- oder heiße wo liegt also das
problem für uns um eine stellt sich
heraus dass die länder von denen wir gas
kaufen nicht sehr vertrauenswürdig sind
und dann ist da noch die tatsache dass
es auch immer weniger erdgas gibt weil
wir nicht mehr die förderung von erdöl
investieren
die industrie für fossile brennstoffe
braucht ständige investitionen damit
ihre reserven nicht erschöpft werden das
problem ist dass der rückgang der
investitionen im erdölsektor 1 kilo
effekt auf erdgas hat es wird erwartet
dass die reserven schneller schrumpfen
da ein großer teil der gasfelder beim
bohren nach öl entdeckt
bis vor kurzem haben wir davon noch
nichts bemerkt dass sich die gaspreise
mehr oder weniger in grenzen hielten
dachten wir es sei alles in butter und
als wir uns schon in falscher sicherheit
wähnten kam aus der kreisstadt daun mit
einem dramatischen rückgang der
nachfrage noch mehr entgegen wir
erreichten sogar einen punkt an dem gas
bereist kostenlos verschenkt wurde der
durchschnittliche hin und herbert
gaspreis 2020 erreicht den niedrigsten
stand seit 25 jahren klar im überfluss
gibt es auch weniger probleme aber
wahrgenommen denn eine tatsache haben
irgendwie alle übersehen ein großer
engpass für den globalen erdgasmarkt ist
der mangel an lng terminals
flüssigerdgas kurz ln sie ist die
einzige möglichkeit gas von orten an
denen es reichlich vorhanden ist wie den
usa australien oder katar an auch das
transportieren an denen ist knapp ist
wie europa und asien dafür braucht man
aber am abgang sword terminals an denen
das gas verflüssigt und den tanker
geladen wird und am ankunftsort braucht
man ebenso terminal sind flüssig erdgas
aus den tankern wieder reduziert wird um
sind pipeline weiter zu portieren aber
der bau von terminals braucht viel zeit
sie sind also keine kurzfristige lösung
und so mussten sehr schmerzlich
feststellen dass die gleichen faktoren
die erdgas beim ausbruch der pandemie
billiger gemacht haben jetzt zu einem
massiven pendelt ausschlag in die andere
richtung geführt haben
der perfekte sturm
es sieht so aus als ob das schlimmste
teil der krise vorbei ist denn die
wirtschaft ist nach den massiven
einschränkungen wie wir im jahr 2020
erlebt haben wieder auf wachstumskurs
das hat jedoch direkte auswirkungen auf
den energiesektor denn die welt verlangt
wieder nach öl kohle und vor allem gas
wir haben es also mit einer enormen
nachfrage nach gas zu tun zu einer zeit
in der das angebot geringer ist als
früher weil die investitionen in fossile
brennstoffe schon vor einer ganzen weile
eingebrochen sind
die auswirkungen eines solchen
investitions defizit kommen jedoch auch
unter normalen umständen nur mit einer
gewissen verzögerung beim endkunden an
und in diesem fall gab es noch einmal
eine weitere galgenfrist durch die
korona schafft aus diese ist jedoch
verstrichen und nun kommen sie die
auswirkungen verspätet aber dafür mit
doppelter wucht mit der verschärfung der
globalen energiekrise schießen die
gaspreise in die höhe in dieser
situation haben viele ihre
aufmerksamkeit auf russland gerichtet
die europäische union beschuldigt den
kräne direkt nicht genug gas für die
europäischen märkte anzubieten einige
spekulieren dass russland die gas
verknappung als druckmittel einsetzt um
endlich die betriebsgenehmigung für nord
stream zwei sondern neue gaspipeline
nach deutschland zu bekommen doch nichts
könnte weiter von der wahrheit entfernt
sein
der letzte winter war sehr kalt und so
wie die europäischen vorräte zu dieser
jahreszeit lehrer sind als sonst mussten
auch die russen ihre eigenen vorräte
wieder auffüllen die gute nachricht ist
dass sie aktuell wieder in der lage zu
sein scheinen europa etwas mehr gas
anzubieten der gaspreise fallen nach
putins befehl die russischen exporte zu
erhöhen doch die schlechten nachrichten
welche angesichts der energiewende auf
die eu zu rollen kann selbst ein
mächtiger mann wie putin nicht immer
aufhalten aber will er das überhaupt die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas ist
immer noch sehr groß ungefähr ein
drittel des in europa verbrauchten gases
kommt aus dem osten damit zeigt sich
einmal mehr wie verwundbar brüssel
berlin und andere große europäische
hauptstädte gegenüber dem kreml sind die
serien wohlwollen putins ausgeliefert
sind dem wohlwollen putins und natürlich
dem von petrus tja man muss erst mal
einen moment innehalten und sich die
jetzige situation vor augen führen
beschreiben das jahr 2021 wie haben sich
wohl die menschen vor 30 jahren das jahr
2020 vorgestellt bestimmt irgendwie sei
mäßig alles total high tech ein leben im
überfluss und ohne sorgen vor allem was
die energie betrifft und jetzt machen
wir mal wieder auf die realität ist
nämlich die europäische union hat sich
mit ihrer energiepolitik so verwundbar
wie noch nie gegenüber russland und dem
wetter gemacht und fassbar wir haben
bereits gesehen welche auswirkungen ein
strenger winter auf die preise hatte
aber auch der sommer war tödlich
energiepreise in europa erreichen
rekorde nachdem der wind aufgehört hat
zu wehen es klingt wie ein treppenwitz
der geschichte die vier größten seine
der bahn haben sich also auch gegen die
eu klimapolitiker verschworen frühling
sommer herbst und winter während des
sommers ist die produktion von windstrom
in europa um fast die hälfte
zurückgegangen denn wenn es keinen wind
gibt gibt es natürlich probleme
da die nachfrage aber trotzdem stieg und
kein wind wehte blieb keine andere wahl
als erdgas zu verbrennen um die
stromnachfrage zu decken und das
schlimmste ist das ist absolut keine
garantie dafür gibt dass dieses szenario
nicht jederzeit wieder eintritt was
bleibt ist also die frage welche
lösungen es jetzt noch gibt der erste
weg um einen gas mangel zu vermeiden
liegt auf der hand die erdgas felder
sind vorhanden also kann immer mehr gas
gefördert werden das problem ist dass
diese lösung ein gewisses maß an
investitionen erfordert und es ein paar
jahre dauern würde bis diese früchte
tragen eine andere möglichkeit ist den
energiemix um andere alternativen zu
erweitern wie das geht nun ich könnte es
mir verraten aber es wäre besser wenn
will geht es dir erklären würde wir
erwarten für verlässlichkeit vom
stromnetz und das meer mehr seltsame
wetterbedingungen haben werden wir
müssen uns also wirklich fragen ist es
die kernenergie ist ist die speicherung
wie können sie die zuverlässigkeit
aufrechterhalten tja und dann wäre da
noch die einfachste alternative die
energiewende mit all ihren opfern und
mängeln zu akzeptieren das würde
bedeuten dass wir die situation lächeln
hinnehmen und sehr tief in unsere
taschen greifen um mehr für energie zu
bezahlen tja das problem dabei ist nur
dass sich das nicht nur auf deine
persönliche energieabrechnung ausgesagt
sondern dass auch die industrie mehr für
energie bezahlen wird und sie dir das
durch höhere preise für ihre produkte in
rechnung stellt mit anderen worten die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit geht erstmal flöten
natürlich kann sich europa diese option
nicht leisten denn das würde bedeuten
weiter an boden zu verlieren
schließlich ist die europäische
industrie welche das geld für die ganzen
investitionen in die energiewende
erwirtschaften muss nicht das
beamtenheer in brüssel oder berlin diese
können nur die von anderen also von der
industrie geschaffene werte umverteilen
nicht mehr und nicht weniger und eines
ist dabei klar ohne günstiges gas können
wir das mit der wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
industrie erst einmal vergessen die
ausweitung der gasförderung ist jedoch
auch deswegen nicht einfach da die
wichtigsten gasfelder der welt außerhalb
unseres kontinents liegen holen siehe da
die not scheint so groß zu sein dass
noch zeichen und wunder geschehen längst
ad acta gelegte button werden plötzlich
wieder aufgerollt plötzlich geht es doch
wieder ideologiefrei
den weg für das grüne revival der
atomkraft der entscheidende punkt dabei
ist dass die kernenergie keine
treibhausgase ausstößt diese erste krise
der energiewende hat uns also gelehrt
dass die kernenergie immer noch eine
option ist die man in betracht ziehen
sollte erstens weil niemand bereit ist
mehr für energie zu bezahlen zweitens
weil die erneuerbaren energien immer
noch nicht ausreichen um den gesamten
bedarf zu decken und grundlaststrom so
oder so immer benötigt werden wird ein
beispiel dafür ist spanien das strom aus
frankreich importieren muss dessen
strommix hauptsächlich aus kernenergie
besteht und aus marokko das kohle
verbrannt und schließlich weil viele
zwar auf den verzicht auf atomkraft
beharren aber dabei vergessen dürfen
dass die gaspreis krise viele länder
dazu gebracht hat ihre kohlekraftwerke
wieder anzuwerfen diese leute haben
gemerkt dass man sich beim waschen eben
doch nachts machen muss auch wenn sie
das verdammt lange nicht wahrhaben
wollten denn die ich schon sagte es gibt
nur zwei optionen entweder wird die
energiewende auf solider realistische
und nicht überstürzt der planung beruhen
oder sie wird so oder so allein durch
die unerbittliche kraft der naturgesetze
und marktmechanismen ins stottern kommen
viele atomkraftgegner deren kritik in
der vergangenheit sicher zu großen
teilen berechtigt war werden ihr urteil
vor allem angesichts der technischen
verfügbarkeit von den reaktoren der
vierten generation und grund auf
überdenken müssen denn diese sind der
große game changer was die sicherheit
und umweltverträglichkeit er keine
energie angeht diese reaktoren haben ein
vollkommen anderes risiko profil die
unfallgefahr ist dramatisch gesunken sie
können auch den radioaktiven abfall der
älteren kraftwerke nutzen und sowieso
toben mit relativ kurzen zerfalls zeiten
verbrennen so dass eine sichere
endlagerung keine produkte mehr
darstellt so ist mit ihnen eine
energiewende denkbar die nicht wie ein
wirtschaftlicher amoklauf wirkt aber
jetzt ist die frage an dich gerichtet
würdest du der kernenergie eine neue
chance geben oder würdest du alles auf
die entwicklung der erneuerbaren
energien setzen wir werden euch in
dieser hinsicht natürlich weiterhin auf
dem laufenden halten gerade das thema
der gern vier reaktoren ist hierbei ja
extrem spannend aber das tut mir in
einem anderen video wie immer sind wir
jetzt erst mal auf eure meinung zu
diesem thema gespannt wie ich hoffe also
dass euch das video gefallen hat falls
ja gibt uns mit einem like teil des mit
euren freunden ist nicht das abo mit
glöckchen und keines unserer videos mehr
zu verpassen und unterstützt unsere
arbeit bitte auch mit einer kleinen
spende über den link in der beschreibung
unter diesem video macht's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]